One of the most surprising things I
think that people learn when you study
perception and you look at the research
is that we can be influenced,
uh,
as perceivers by stereotypes that we
don't even believe are true,
uh,
so you don't have to be racist or,
or be a chauvinist or be at any,
any kind of a bad person to be
influenced by stereotypes.
It turns out all you need to do is know
the stereotype to be influenced by it.
Stereotypes really are,
uh,
are an example of categorization.
Brains are,
have evolved.
Human brains have evolved to be very
rapid categorizes of things.
It's what allows us to interact with our
world so smoothly and effectively.
Right?
So you can go into a room and see a
chair for the first time and you know
that it's for sitting and not for eating
or climbing because you identify it as a
member of the category.
Chair.
Stereotypes are categories of people and
sometimes they're actually very helpful.
So we have stereotypes of what police
officers are.
Librarians are nurses are like.
And those stereotypes allow us to fill
in the blanks a little bit and know
without even talking to a member of that
profession,
something about what their job is,
how I'm supposed to interact with them,
what it's reasonable to ask of them,
you know,
how our interaction is probably going to
go.
The problem of course,
is that every stereotype is a
generalization.
I'm the done never applies completely
accurately to any one person.
And sometimes stereotypes are just flat
out wrong.
Um,
they're,
they're just,
they're just absolutely a unnecessarily
negative and completely untrue.
And yet we are affected by them because
again,
that's one of these phase one perception
things that,
that the activation of stereotypes in
the mind is odd,
relatively automatic.
For example,
I'm a female scientist and there are
stereotypes about women not being as
capable in science and mathematics.
So I like to get right out in front with
people and you know,
show them,
demonstrate my expertise in science and
math.
And so that I can counter that
stereotype before it has a chance to
negatively affect their view of me.
Particularly when the perceiver isn't
really motivated to be accurate about
you or is only getting really a kind of
a quick glimpse of you when they're
really kind of busy thinking about other
things.
That's when all of these things are at
their sort of the highest danger of,
of influencing and getting in the way of
being seen the way you really want to.
So as as the person who is being
perceived really what you want to be
able to do is get that other person to
really want to see you accurately.
The the best ways to do that are to get
that person to work with you in some way
or to get that person to to to to notice
that you can help them reach their
goals.
That's another really great way to get
people to,
to kind of get past the initial
assumptions and really take a second
look at you.
So be someone who's instrumental in
helping other people reach their goals
and they're going to be much more likely
to try to see the real.
You.